the australian consul was among the last
group of people to go to the prison
island where the inmates were killed
but her presence could do nothing to
save the two australian citizens
executed by firing squad along with the
six others just after midnight local
time
earlier relatives of the condemned also
traveled to the prison to say their
final goodbyes the woman in the black
sunglasses is the cousin of brazilian
convict rodrigo gulate
since i'm here three months
today is the day that rodrigo is more
calm
yeah he's calm he
he doesn't want i cry
the execution of the prisoners has
caused an international outcry
caused by demonstrators in the
philippines to save their national mary
jane veloso appear to have been
successful at least for the time being
the mother of two was not among those
shot at midnight
but speaking shortly before the
executions the indonesian attorney
general explained why his country was so
hard on drug convicts
what we are fighting against is serious
crime drugs
i ask that everyone understand this and
do not pressure us to postpone or cancel
the execution
because if we postpone or cancel it
proves that indonesia is weak in its war
against drugs
so jakarta is standing its ground in the
hope this will deter future criminals